hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome back to my channel you know
it's been about a month since I've
posted some videos because we've been
working on the new version of orderflows
Traders it's orderflows Trader 8 which
is the next generation of orderflows
Trader and you know I'm excited about a
lot of the new tools on there because I
really think that it's going to help
Traders uh with their orderflow analysis
and you know one of the tools that uh
We've added on here is the Delta
change uh data right because you know at
the end of the day
all the information that you're looking
at in the order flow you know what
trades on the bid what trades on the
offer how it trades um you know with in
terms of volume is information it's data
right and from that data you can
extrapolate it into useful forms of
analysis and you know one of the sort of
the basic tools of order flow is just
the Delta right so when you look at a
bar you see the bar is got Delta of
245 okay like this green bar over here
and you know what that is it's the
difference between the net aggressive
buying in a bar and the net aggressive
selling in the bar and it's 245 and
generally speaking you know Green bars
have positive Delta red bars have
negative Delta you know there are
instances where you do have a green bar
with negative Delta or a red bar with
positive Delta and that does mean
something as well but you know one of
the the things with Delta when when
you're looking at just raw Delta numbers
by themselves right you just analyze in
it on a Barby bar basis
and you know while that's okay and you
can make good trading decisions based
off of that you know why not take it a
step further and put it in context with
what just happened on the previous bar
so what we've added down here at the
bottom is the Delta change okay so you
can see you know for example um up here
at this little at this High here okay
we've got positive Delta of 4
437 and then next bar has got a Delta of
44 so it's both positive Deltas but
there's an actual change from 437 to 44
right it's negative Delta of 393 now
it's still showing green because it is
still positive Delta I didn't want to
confuse people by changing that to a red
color um you know we've all got eyes we
can see that it's a negative number okay
then you can see the next bar it's got
Delta of -
718 all right so it's negative but it's
a change from positive 44 to - 718 which
gives you a change of
762 between the two bars now don't get
confused because sometimes people will
look at the Delta change and they're so
used to looking at say the Delta number
or you know um like the max Min that
they see- 393 then - 762 and they sort
of conflate it with you know that's the
change from the minus you know here's
249 to- 393 being 76 - 76 no it's not
it's the change from bar one to Bar two
in terms of Delta so you can see - 718
to -
522 okay that's actually a slight
increase in Delta to 196 right it's
still negative but it's an increase you
know when you're looking at the number
line from - 718
to um 522 uh minus 522 which is positive
186 just as - 522 to - 391 it's an
increase actually of 131 and you often
see that as a market starts stalling
even though the Deltas are negative
right they're not really um growing in
the negative sense okay so how how can
you use this well you know there there's
a couple ways
one way that I like to use it right is
is I like to look at how the Delta is
changing when we are coming into a swing
high or say a swing low now the cash
open over here you know it's Monday
morning um March 10th so you know you
see just a lot of Delta coming in
because volume is increasing but you
know over here it's about 15 minutes
after the cash open you know markets
have pretty much settled down and and
they're sort of doing what they're going
to do and okay so we're coming into a
swing High you know you got a nice
positive Delta up here at this High
437 but then just noticing the Delta
change right goes from 430 37 to just 44
obviously to - 718 and I see that Delta
change is - 393 right after the swing
High then obviously - 762 which is quite
strong we get a nice little sell off
there and you know over here right we
got you know this nice little sell-off
coming in here now you know what was
interesting is this Market is just more
or less going sideways obviously we got
the big negative Delta in this bar with
- 1313 Delta the Delta change -5 100 I
mean it's a big change but you know this
Deltas have kind of petered out here
we're just you know 300- 391 plus 200
plus 200 then minus 13 it's already a
big sign in in the Delta but still
nevertheless it is a strong you know
Delta change to the negative side then
we come down in here to the swing
low we've got Delta of- 628 and then
this bar right here plus 720 so it's a
Delta change from- 128 back to 0 plus
720 which gives you a Delta change of
1348 okay then again it doesn't look
like much of a move here but you know
this Market is pretty you know volatile
here just this move from here is 93 up
almost up to uh o but it's up to 99
that's a quick
six uh six points right there easy easy
Five Points um coming in so that's how
you know you could use things like Delta
change to analyze what's taking place in
the market okay and you know this is the
e- minis um you know it same sort of
concept is going to work in other
markets now this is the ultra bonds okay
and again you know I like looking at
potential reversal signs you know
somewhere you know at a high or at a low
you cuz you know anytime that I'm going
to get some good information you know
for potential trade you know I think
reversals are a great opportunity to
catch a maj move so if there's anything
that's that I can glean from the order
flow at a high of the day or or the low
of the day um you know it's I think it
sets you up for a great trading
opportunity so we're up here at the high
of the day and you see the Delta
positive 350 which is what you expect to
see at the high of the day right nice
strong positive right because we are
going higher but obviously this candle
reversed it's a red candle down actually
at the high of the day but the Delta is
still positive okay so and again you
know like I alluded to earlier sometimes
you have bars that have you know a red
candle with positive Delta which is a
sign of of
some Traders absorbing whatever
aggressive buy is taking place here and
then the next bar minus 202 so again you
know what went what went on here we had
positive Delta of 350 then the next bar
is -200 so it's actually a
swing of -550
cuz it went from 350 down to 0er then
down to
-202 gives you a change of -5 52 okay
which is quite a strong number in terms
of the Deltas that you're looking at
here in the ultra bonds then obviously
the next bar you know really cements the
fact that this Market is selling off um
goes from- 202 to- 927 that's a Delta
change of -
725 but really the the signs were up
here right this is going to give you a
nice trading opportunity where's your
stop going to be it's just going to be
above the high of the day right cuz you
know you're looking for that reversal
off of this
high and you know it goes from you know
13 down to you know 6 7 easily right
there but again you know that's how you
can use the Delta change to find you
know potential reversals just as we're
going back up here back up into this
High obviously this bar here has got you
know very strong positive Delta of a
th000 you see the Delta change of
876 which is a strong Delta change but
to begin with you know a th000 is
already um a strong Delta number okay
you do see a nice pick up here um with
the Delta change percentage because now
you can put that in a percentage as well
okay so you know there's different ways
you can use that and you know to take it
a step
further what we've done
with order flow Trader is we've added it
into the actual settings in here so if
you were to scroll down
into the indicator settings you could
find um where is it Delta
change here we go Delta change threshold
okay and again yeah you could filter it
by coming in at swing highs when it
comes in momentum and you can adjust
what you want your thresh told to be you
know what amount you know whether you
know the default is 750 you know if
you're trading e- mini 750 is is is good
um you know other markets you might want
to have a a different number you know
Ultra bonds I think 500 is good and now
you could have Zone placement you know
how you want to draw the zones out in
the direction of the bar opposite
direction or both I'll just put it on
both here just to show you what it looks
like and just click apply
okay and you're going to see here so
it's red and blue okay so you can see
it's coming in right here there's
another one coming in here here's your
bullish one coming in here okay yeah
bearish one there um another nice
bullish one coming in right here as
we're breaking out into new highs there
was a bearish one here followed by a
bullish okay so again you know it's
going to help you determine what's
taking place in the market by reading
the change Delta as opposed to just
Delta itself okay so it takes the Delta
analysis a step further you know and in
my weekly uh training sessions that I do
every Friday for users of the order
flows Trader software I go over stuff
like this and how you can use this how
you can implement it in your trading to
get the most out of all the tools
because now we got a total of like 56
tools in the orderflows trader software
so again you know if you enjoy these
videos on orderflow be sure to subscribe
to the channel so when I post a new one
you're going to be notified and if you
like this video be sure to hit the like
button right because uh you know at the
end of the day that's what keeps me
going is is um you know people's
interest in orderflow so thanks everyone
and I'll see you guys on the next video